you forget what's up plenty of action
with the Avengers and you died hey
youtubers this charlie tonight's a big
night of TV we have agents of shield and
supernatural is back this is my agents
of shield video and as predicted we got
to see our first supervillain or at
least we get to see someone become our
first super villain on the show so the
episode was really like a science-based
techy episode and the big runner the red
herring was the gravitonium the element
they used in this device that would kind
of allow them to exploit more resources
from the earth but dr. Franklin Hall who
was the asset as the title of the
episode implies basically wanted to stop
this it was a bit misleading throughout
the episode just because you kind of
thought that he had switched over and
become a bad person but like a lot of
people in the comic book world when
someone really has this crazy idea and
thinks they're doing the right thing
they usually end up becoming a villain
and at the end of this episode dr.
Franklin Hall basically becomes graviton
so there's a couple important things to
talk about in this episode one is the
tech like the big Marvel aspects of it
that they included in the story the
comic-book aspects that the gravitonium
dr. Franklin Hall and graviton the
important continuing plot lines and some
of the ships that are going on the one
let's talk about the text cuz it has a
lot to do with the way they use people
in this episode so obviously Chloe
Bennet's character Skye got most of the
scenes they're kind of using hers like
the fish-out-of-water character so
naturally I'm not surprised they used
her a lot but I really feel like her
character is just an analog for the
emily Thorne character on revenge so
whenever you see Skye's character think
of Emily VanCamp
in the Marvel Universe oh wait they're
doing that already it's called Captain
America the Winter Soldier
speaking of tech let's talk about the
actual device so I really like
science-based episodes just because I'm
a big science nerd if you ever watch
Stargate Atlantis I really like the
episodes that Rodney McCain the science
teams had they just dealt with really
really big scientific problems and
usually the solutions involve this
really complex math problem that was not
the case in this episode and I feel like
Marvel is just kind of trying to dumb
things down a little bit so I didn't
really appreciate that as much but I
don't blame them and they are trying to
play it safe this is only the third
episode but I'm really looking forward
to some future episode where they really
delve deep into like some huge math
problem and just visualize it in some
really awesome way and what about the
ships so I
see there are a couple running ships I
know a lot of people are shipping Mae
and Colson they have more of a mature
relationship and I really do feel like
Mae is totally in on whatever happened
to Colson I feel like she knows and
there was that moment at the end where
Colson was talking about muscle memory
and he said I don't know why I'm not
remembering this because I've done it so
many times I feel like that's just a
life model decoy argument but I'll talk
about that later Skye and ward obviously
are the most obvious ship on the show
I'm calling them sward right now I
really feel like the rising tide stuff
is gonna come and bite that in the ass
and there's gonna be some huge betrayal
at some point in the season it just
hasn't happened yet I was really
expecting the rising tide stuff to bite
her in the ass in this episode but they
ended up using it as a central plot
point so that might happen again later
in the season so it'll be interesting to
see how the rising tide kind of affects
all the relationships on the show I
really do feel like the sky sexytime
moments were a little bit funny
especially when she was trying to trick
the villain into giving her information
I give her a high five for that high
five to the new girl so obviously we
have the biggest moment of the episode
let me know what you thought about that
end teaser the actual graviton
transformation they have great special
effects on this show as opposed to say
like Sleepy Hollow last night which did
this gateway to hell storyline and the
special effects just look terrible let
me know if you think though what do you
think of the special effects on shield
and what did you think of that graviton
transformation but now let's talk a
little bit about magic life model decoys
and clones
so obviously that end beat with Coulson
really kind of teased up the idea that
his body is not the same body so that's
either clone or life model decoy and
obviously there's the magical Tahiti
storyline - I really feel like Tahiti is
just an actual magical place like like
Doctor Strange magic so I'll talk more
about magic in a future episode be sure
to subscribe to get it
don't forget arrow season 2 as I
mentioned earlier is coming back
tomorrow I'll be doing a video for that
too also if you don't follow me on
tumblr or you didn't see my Sleepy
Hollow video Supernatural season 9 is
back tonight - I did a video for that
you can click here to watch it you can
also click here to watch all my other
agents of shield videos so remember
arrow season 2 back tomorrow and
American Horror Story coven I'll be
doing videos for both of those things be
sure to subscribe to get them thanks so
much for watching high fives